fifty Shades freed hits theaters soon
the ACMA conclusion of The Twilight fan
fiction master of the universe but did
you skip the first two movies you did do
you need a refresher on what's happening
before you see the third yes oh yes you
do because this is one of the most
insanely awful sagas in cinema and I am
NOT just referring to the lukewarm sexy
no I'm talking about the really sinking
the plot the characters as our story
begins college student Anastasia Steele
heads to Seattle to interview important
eligible billionaire Christian Grey
who's kind of like Batman - the costume
with double the baggage symbolism Anna
is covering for her roommate Kate miss
Kavanagh has the flu so she asked me to
fill it because that's how interviews
work you don't reschedule you just send
your roommate of course Anna and
Christian hit it off right away just
listen to this electric banter there's
some people who say that I don't have a
heart at all they say that because they
know me well charming it goes so well in
fact that Christian shows up at Anna's
work the very next day which is
completely unlike something a stalker
would do he makes them not at all creepy
and suggestive purchases rope tape cable
ties you're the complete serial killer
not today he also sets up a photo shoot
with Anna and Kate how about we try a
few with the smile
that of course turns into a second date
I find you intimidating you should I
don't know dudes so far you seem pretty
terrible at your job and we're all
secretly wishing you were Charlie Hunnam
so I kind of feel bad for you anyway at
coffee we begin to get some hints that
Christian gets his views on dating from
Maxim magazine I don't do the girlfriend
thing and also that he maybe has an
Irish accent you should stare at me Ana
keeps her distance for as long as she
can but after drunk-dialing Christian he
shows up at the bar and valiantly
rescues her from her suddenly handsy
photographer friend she said no
Christian finally starts to come clean
about what his deal is I don't do
romance my tastes are very singular but
could he be more specific I don't make
love hard
potato potato look I thought these
movies were about freaky bondage stuff
are we do this or not I want you to
willingly surrender yourself to me
please me there we go Christian doesn't
want to go out with Ana he wants to make
her his submissive he even shows her
around his playroom which I believe is
referred to in the lore the Red Room of
pain this is the only sort of
relationship I have but before they can
get into any of the actual sex
first there's foreplay and by foreplay I
mean several rounds of litigation I
already have a contract prepared if you
would review it and we would negotiate
what you are and are not willing to try
it takes a while is the use of sex toys
acceptable to the submissive vibrators
okay dildos fine
[Music]
once that's out of the way they do it
eventually they settle into a pattern
where Christian frustrates Anna with his
rules and regulations shouldn't get
drunk like that you put yourself at risk
last night
what's your unashamed of your nakedness
do you understand sexy punishment if you
were mine you wouldn't be able to sit
down for Olli
welcome to my world but then he always
makes it up to her the only way a sad
broken person knows how buying her luck
back in vehicle for him happy graduation
Anastasia Christian that's a car
sufficiently purchased Anna asked
Christian to let her in and see how
intense his playroom sessions can get
Christian complies I'm gonna hit you six
times then Anna gets super upset the
Christian showed her how intense this
playroom sessions can get don't come
near me
Anna decides to leave for good which is
the happiest possible ending this is not
a healthy relationship Christian but of
course there is an ambiguous ending in
more movies little uh find out what
happened next time by which I mean right
now party begins we were joined everyone
one year later Anna has a new job
working as an assistant for high-powered
editor Jack Hyde a name almost as on the
nose as grey good morning sir
Christian is still being Christian by
which we mean a quote psychopath he's
having nightmares about his traumatic
childhood
and the not so happy couple is still
broken up are you ever gonna tell me
what happened between you fundamental
differences in yes then Christian
randomly appears at Jose's new photo
exhibition and buys all the pictures of
Anna yes these were the actions of a
psychotic stalker technically but he's a
billionaire who looks like an underwear
model so it's cool anna agrees to have
dinner with him for some ungodly reason
and christian reveals that he's willing
to compromise if Anna will come back to
him he'll give up his elaborate romantic
rules and regulations no rules no
punishments do you need all those things
I need you more at first things seem
great but soon Christians old
controlling behavior rears its head
again you're gonna be my boss
technically I'll be your boss's boss's
boss why do you have my bank account
details at this point we're all just
yelling at the screen live woman right
around the point where most people are
forsaking God for giving them eyes and
ears to experience this movie something
actually happens yeah a strange woman
starts talking Anna who turns out to be
a former submissive of Christians she's
of course recently lost her mind which
is definitely all on her and has nothing
to do with how awful Christian is
because these movies are awful when you
and I were in Georgia together she
turned up here and try just let it rest
some fella mrs. Jones my housekeeper
back at work Anna's boss sexually
assault sir I just that's a real line in
a real movie Christian gets him fired
and this is big because this is the
first time that Christian has used his
obsessive stalker powers for good
hi Joe you can fire Anna gets this job
because much like journalism publishing
also operates by replacing someone with
literally the closest person nearby okay
you so what are you filling for Jack
temporarily good things are going better
with Christian and Anna finds that she's
starting to enjoy the playroom more and
more because the Stockholm Syndrome is
strong with this one if I win
take me to the Red Room then they have a
few minor scrapes with death like any
young relationship
Leila Christians crazy act shows that
the Anna's place with a gun I came to
see you but Christian saves the day
through the powers of his domination
after that Christian is in a terrifying
helicopter accident over Mount st.
Helens but three blissful minutes were
left to imagine that he's dead but
because this movie's delights in your
pain he's fine and emerges with no more
than a few little smudges on his
handsome but not Charlie Hunnam face
this short-lived plot device finally
convinces the couple that they should
get married Anna says yes be a
commemorative keychain and then he asks
her even more formally early finally the
happy couple enjoys fireworks and we cut
to a mysterious smoking man watching
from a bar could it be the evil ex
publisher out for a revenge against the
two people he blames through his
professional demise yes obviously yes
yes yes it can if that's what it is
which you can see soon in the thrilling
conclusion of the 50 sheets saga don't
say we didn't warn you